blue background with ones and zeros Text
data science data science basically is
just the set of methodologies and Tech
and text PubMed search screen appears
that are used
extract Knowledge from data Lisa Fetter
or PhD mlis data science and open
science Librarians so how do we get from
a big
big bold text Miriam's Erin Glam PhD
data science and open science officer
part of
hard for people to find data and then
ultimately make use of it two different
web pages for ncbi's genome resources
appear nlm has been involved in Data
before data science was even really a
term we have the national Center for
biotechnology information which is a
really incredible data resource for
people that are working with biomedical
data of all different types and we have
a lot of other resources that we make
available like PubMed to provide access
to the literature so really we have been
involved in making information and data
available to people for a long time
cityscape at night with streams of
flowing data we're in this moment where
we have genomics Technologies and we
have wearables that are collecting
information from us we have computerized
clinical records and all of these
different data sources that if we could
combine them and figure out you know
what are the best forms of analysis we
can really accelerate the speed of
biomedical Discovery and we have the
kind of expertise at nlm that allows us
to not only make data available but do
research that that really advances data
science word map with words language
processing learning surrounding large
NLP particularly in the areas of things
like natural language processing which
in
which in the science techniques to
extract information from text
when we think of a library we sort of
think of books on a shelf and Librarians
as people handing books to us animated
blue timeline builds left to right
showing blast 1990 PubMed 1998 PubMed
Central 2001 and dbgap 2008. but really
nlm has this long track record of making
data available to different users and
all of these different types of ways
like any Library we exist to make
information available to people and now
we're doing that in a way that fits with
the modern techniques and technologies
that we have available to us through
data science approaches NIH nlm gray and
blue logo with underlying gray text
serving scientists and Society